[Music]
in Iran four traffic police officers
have been killed in what officials are
calling a terrorist attack in the
Southeastern city of zaidan an arrest
warrant has been issued for the
perpetrators the motive behind the
attack at this stage still unclear let's
go live to dorsa Jabari Dorsey urine
Tehran what do you know about what
happened and perhaps why it happened
well we know very little about what
happened according to the reports we
have received so far from officials from
the Southeastern province of system
baluchistan this attack was carried out
a few hours ago by unknown gunmen who
targeted these traffic police officers
on a highway stretch between two cities
in that Province the officials are now
looking for the gunmen they haven't
specified how many men they're looking
for but the Manhunt is underway as we
understand it and this is of course
something that the officials here take
very seriously as that area is prone to
these attacks over the past few years
can you give us a little bit more
context on this region the people of
Balochistan regularly allege that they
are repressed and they are discriminated
against
well system Lucha San is one of the
biggest provinces in Iran it's home to
nearly 2 million people and most of them
are the Sunni minority group in this
country but the disputes that have been
ongoing between officials there and a
number of armed groups that have been
designated as terrorist organizations by
Iran by Iran are something that has been
a problem for this country and its
security apparatus there is a well-known
group a separatist Sunni separatist
group known by the name of jaesh al-at
that was formed in 2012. the main goal
is to separate that region from Iran due
to its Sunni majority members in that
region living in that region and the
authorities have designated the group as
a terrorist organization having said
that the province is also bordering
Pakistan and Afghanistan it's one of the
main drug trafficking routes as we have
heard from officials here so there is a
lot of activity in that region and is
one of the main issues that the
officials have been dealing with for
this specific incident we don't know yet
exactly the reason behind it at the
moment but it is something that the
officials are looking into for now dorsa
Jabari reporting from Tehran thank you
very much dorsa